oh boy it's going to be a beautiful day
on a Friday I can't wait to shoot
outside with my two best friends you
better be excited for the Assassin's
Creed movie because it's going to be a
milestone film that proves that video
game movies can actually be good
according to the people making the movie
the people making the movie chattered to
Microsoft's Major Nelson about how great
the movies gonna be where lead actor
Michael Fassbender dropped in gems like
on screen is a different experience and
as a gamer you go into this world and
it's your world in this film we're
presenting a universe and you're
somewhat of a passenger I mean you're
not wrong that is how movies work
Fassbender has not only grasped the
difference between movies and games
though he also did ninety-five percent
of his own stunts in the film which is
pretty sweet unfortunately that five
percent he didn't do does include the
120 foot leap of faith scene which was
performed by a stuntman haystak landing
pads I get to be confirmed at this stage
Fassbender is already signed on for
multiple sequels that she can catch the
first assassin's creed movie on december
21 this week tactical multiplayer
shooter fans found their stocking
stuffed early when ubisoft released
their latest midseason reinforcements
patch for rainbow 6 siege everyone's
favorite russian to chunk up has been
rebalanced and updated after OV noticed
he had the lowest quick rate of any
character they discovered the trade-off
between his turret stopping power and
his lack of mobility led two attackers
having several ways to take him out the
update as a shield to chunk his turret
to protect him from head shots in the
direction he's facing and all shield
operators will now have directional
explosion resistance there's also a
bunch of changes to operators and
weaponry balances bug fixes and the
addition of the Bartlet University
mapping of PvP modes previously only
available as part of the PvE situations
and terrorist hunt the devs have
redesigned the map for PvP by removing
all the gas and PvE elements
implementing better to layer destruction
and improving the visual layout for
better orientation for all the details
on what's new in Rainbow six siege check
out our story on gamespot
Christmas is cancelled because
everyone's playing on you ever watched
update cold winter wonderland this new
event once again replaces the standard
loot boxes giving you the chance to get
at least one new Christmas item there
are a ton of new voice lines emotes
poses highlight intros and of course the
skins the in skins tour Bjorn is Santa
Winston finally gets a good legendary
and look at this in yard and Nutcracker
one the update also gives Hannah Mora
and kings row a winter makeover and
introduces a new brawl cordon maze
snowball offensive it's a single
elimination annica point Antarctica
everyone is May and everyone can only
shoot one snowball before having to find
more snow to reload and it's actually
pretty intense fun winter wonderland
will be live until January 2nd next year
and in your weekly dose of cringe
Nintendo tried to run a Pokemon Sun and
Moon challenge and it did not go well
I'm talking a massive loss so the plan
was to organize worldwide challenge for
every Sun and Moon player sweet idea no
problem so far the event began in
November and challenge players to
collectively catch 100 million pokemon
across the two games 100 million wow
that seems like a big number did they
research that to check they had the
engagement levels to achieve that sort
of thing it seems not so what it plainly
players did not catch them all they did
not even catch most while the English
blog post about the event simply said
that the 100 million goal was just miss
the Japanese announcement pointed out
that trainers worldwide managed to cats
just 16.5 million Pokemon so that's less
than 100 million beating the challenge
would have rewarded every participant
with 100 festival coin as a consolation
prize they all received 100 crummy
regular coins oh well it is now time for
the patch notes part of our show this
week we take a look at battlefield one
this week battlefield one got a major
update and its first free map giant
shadow here's what's changed set in the
shadow of a giant crashed airship the
map takes place in the Battle of cell in
1918 this Maps behemoth is the armored
train choo-choo spectator mode you can
now watch your friends get shot by a
sniper from across the map new custom
game mode that only let you use standard
issue rifles
movement and Amos has been updated for
all soldiers vehicle deployment and
balancing has also been updated oh man
so have weapons and gadgets and finally
there's a bunch of stability UI and
audio fixes you can check out gamespot
com for the full list of updates do you
remember we're just four days away from
our livestream countdown off gamespot's
top five games of the year you can catch
up on December twentieth at ten a.m.
pacific so come by to find out our
favorite games of the year tell us yours
and potentially grab yourself some
prizes and that is it from the
Australian team the GSV this year the US
will be taken care I'll be next week but
be sure to have yourselves a lovely
holiday break eat a lot for your play a
lot of games and we will see you in the
new year
[Music]